what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves an
official trailer trailer number dose for
the Super Mario movie standing by how's
it going I'ma doing a super how are you
Gregory I would love it if they leave it
a like anywho we will not do that for
the rest of the video I promise you
Chris Pratt Will let's get to it guys
let's see what this trailer's all about
[Music]
this exciting oh yeah
continue
is that Donkey Kong
oh
my God okay
not sure if you knew who I am but I'm
about to rule the world
wow
yay but there's one problem
yeah it's a mustache you just like you
do you think I know every human
with the letter of his first name on it
because I don't
Bowser is coming
Peach's voice we
are going to stop that monster heves the
badass look at us
adorable
oh cool
yes that's great
get it out get it up get it off
oh no the raccoon yeah the fireballs
they're all wow
he even hit Mario Karts let's get some
super smash Rainbow Road yes
that orchestral sweet theme song
that looks awesome that looks delightful
okay so you know a lot of us were
thinking that it would probably be about
um you know Peach being kidnapped having
to save her but it looks like that's not
the plot of the movie you know that it's
it's a they're teaming up together and
it seems like the one who's kidnapped
and in danger is actually Luigi yeah my
brother damson and I really like what
it's Charlie Day who's doing the voice
of uh Luigi right I really like The
Voice work of him a lot we got to hear
just a little bit more of Chris Pratt's
Mario I imagine in the actual film
itself it'll sound fine because like the
first time we heard it uh we were taking
it back but the more I've seen the
trailer for the first one the more I'm
like ah it was really fun come on it's
cool I mean just the fact that they're
bringing all this to life with Mushroom
Kingdom the fact that we got Donkey Kong
in here the fact that we got Mario Kart
racing yes absolutely and even the
littlest bits of of like making fun of
more like the 2D games when you're
dealing with having to go through those
obstacles in time when you jump through
things and stuff like that exactly and
things jumping out from underneath you
or whatever and the different different
power-ups you can get you know it's
definitely checked every single box in
terms of all the different uh takes on
the world and the game as the games have
come out of 8-bit into you know full-on
graphical reality I'm skimming this
trailer because what I'm on the lookout
for is we saw the squirrel suit as made
famous in Super Mario 3. okay at one
point here it is all right yeah at one
point uh you see Peach yeah touching the
fire flower so they gotta have the fire
power suits did we see Mario using that
all in this trailer I don't think it's
going back so fast that I I can't really
quite he has he has to if they're going
to be having that suit it's classic and
from Chris Pratt too it's like you know
he's got his Mario voice which sounds
more close to Chris Pratt than I would
have expected given the hype but hearing
him do that little Wahoo with the end
yeah got me giddy I will not deny there
are parts of this where I don't know
where this whole Donkey Kong because
everyone he's surrounded by are other
Kongs so if you're not getting a Kong
Skull Island
this has to be in the mushroom the world
because you have Peach there and Donkey
Kong's dad right there too yeah cranky
Kong's there I guess so yeah I mean it
seems like it's a formalized thing
rather than he's been kidnapped and
taken to sakar or something like that to
fight with the Hulk it's got to be some
type of conch City within here but yeah
looking over the kingdoms and then
everything with Bowser I like odagna
Taylor Joy is doing with the voice of
peach as well this just feels like the
game brought to to life in a very
cinematic way which is what you'd want
and it doesn't seem like you need to be
a lover of the game to want to watch
this movie simultaneously this looks
like kind of the perfect case scenario
for a video game movie because yeah the
Mario games are already really
imaginative they lend themselves to an
animated fantasy anyway that's what
you're playing and so here yeah I would
imagine that people who with Nostalgia
for the game even more so than something
like Sonic probably would be very much
enthralled but also people who have no
Nostalgia for the game can still
probably access this pretty well and not
necessarily need to have all that
lexicon in their head to appreciate it
well it's got like a great sense of
peril as as well I am kind of curious
though because I still felt like Luigi
spoke more in this trailer than Mario
did yes oh my God are they hiding it or
is there a lack of confidence there I
have a little bit I don't want to harp
too much on it because everything else
is firing on all cylinders and working
in such a grand and beautiful way and
it's playing on Nostalgia but it looks
like it's introducing and weaving in new
qualities as well Adam wanted to sound
like a negative video because it's not I
am just a little curious like I thought
they'd probably show more yeah yeah
with all the expansions one thing and
technically we do get more of his voice
but I wonder if maybe you're right and I
can absolutely see whatever the choice
is it'll definitely play better in a
full movie with all that Breathing Room
rather than in a trailer so maybe they
are because again the brief Snippets
we've heard of his dialogue do sound
more like Chris Pratt than a voice yeah
to me anyway more than you know like a
full-on Mario I can't tell it's him even
when he's breathing I can tell it's
Christmas but at this same time this
left a more palatable taste in my mouth
for that so I don't know maybe they're
hiding it but either way they've got so
much else to work with feel like they
just want to Dazzle us with the breadth
of imagination well it's the story of
the plumber who fell into Mushroom
Kingdom who's gonna become a hero Larger
than Life that's right we'll probably
start his own Plumbing business in the
Mushroom Kingdom him and his brother and
all hope is not lost and then we get
that Luigi's Mansion spin-off but guys
I'm excited for this I feel like this
looks great April right yeah let's do it
maybe we'll hold off and do a reaction
on the channel oh I'll be fine Rob the
theater experience from us ladies and
gentlemen leave a like subscribe click
that Bell let's shout out some patrons
Master Big Tease
John the goats My Goats totes the bloats
You've Got a Friend in Me a lot of
answer the bags spicy meatball Wes
Anderson Martin Starr Lauren you be my
American Girl American Boy
I forget the song
complicatedly saturated Joanna Albanese
was always named after me in the roster
growing up in elementary school
Rouge cucaroo Sarah Justice Supermarket
Rosie baby
Slim Shady
stand up Maria humbling oh my God
Mr Anderson backflip Agent J Will Smith
Jr
laughs
if your kids are watching Jen
I want your kids know your hot bomb I
don't know what happened there
it was worth it though
Melania Benoit Blanc
your your guys are a real Glass Onion
all you patrons just layers and layers
of things to appreciate about each and
every one of you y'all are lovely and
there's no mystery
as to why you guys are some of the best
the reject nation has to offer okay but
seriously thank you for being here we we
appreciate you guys and uh you know each
month getting to come up with new and
fun ways of saying all your names I look
forward to that you know
you give us that joy and I hope you get
some Joy from hearing us
warp your names in all different
directions
happy holidays guys
stay sexy Stay classy you just don't
know how to I don't know
anything people gotta just be like I'm
done and I'm like cool me too
[Music]